it's April 2nd 2020 and this is my
monthly update video as everyone knows
we're in the middle of quite a crisis so
there's a lot to be said about that and
I think it may shoot a video
specifically about that so I don't go
into too much detail here I want to put
the focus just on talking about what
went on in March that you might want to
know about and what we've got coming up
in April
there's a lot of cool online events that
you can participate in I always like to
begin by talking about three big things
so big thing number one the wisdom for
life radio show which recently had its
third episode
air is still ongoing my host and I have
found a good mo for a recording despite
being in separate places and not being
able to get into the radio station big
thing number two I did a workshop with
the stoah earlier last month and I'm
doing another one this month on solitude
and cultivating inner life which I'll
talk about in the April section and
finally big thing number three I'm
starting something new that I wanted to
do for quite some time which is going to
be an online event devoted specifically
to talking about classic that is 1970s
and 1980s primarily heavy metal and I'll
tell you more about that in the April
section as well so let's talk about
March first well as all of you know
we're in the middle of the cove in
nineteen pandemic crisis so a lot of
things got canceled
that included my face-to-face events we
did not have the worlds of speculative
fiction series ongoing that was hosted
at the Brookfield Public Library because
all the libraries are closed at this
point and we're not doing public events
I was however able to do quite a few
online events so I had my AMA that has
asked me anything session link to it is
below I did my half hour Hegel
meet ups right where I do Q&A and
discussion both the public one and the
one just for patreon supporters I did a
philosophy pop up specifically on stoic
philosophy and practice we had two
airings of the wisdom for life radio
show and we actually have the honor of
being the last people to do a live show
in studio at River West radio in part
because we showed up without knowing
that the station was officially closed
due to the Cova
pandemic we hadn't received the email so
it came in and we did our show I'll put
the links to those two shows below if
you want to listen to them and what else
we had our Milwaukee stoic fellowship
meeting we did it remotely using zoom
this time and I also did a workshop for
the stoah which is based in Toronto
Canada and I did a workshop specifically
on the virtue of fortitude and how it
helps us deal with failures and failings
so the video for that is available you
can see it below if you're interested in
that topic very important one that we
don't often talk about I think but but
plays a major role in any form of
intentional living so those were the
events I also did a couple podcast
interviews one with the stoic
psychologist and one with the practical
stoic links to those are also listed
below as well and I continued my work
with tutorials and philosophical
counseling and ethics consulting there's
actually a bit more demand for that
right now and you know my classes of
course all of you have heard I think
about the pivot to online so three of my
classes for this semester we're already
online now one of them is in rather
difficult circumstances because it's for
inmates in Wisconsin prisons it's part
of what's called the second-chance Pell
program which I might shoot a video
about that as well that would probably
be a good idea for me to do and
they're mostly in lockdown so so many of
my students can't communicate with me
their their modes of communication we're
already rather limited and we're just
trying to get them through the rest of
the semester and I give them a lot of
content that I load into their their
class Moodle shell so that they can have
a rich learning experience this semester
they're actually doing introduction to
ethics and so I'm having them you know
reading Kant and John Stuart Mill and
and Mary Wollstonecraft and Aristotle
and people like that and I give them the
videos that you've seen in the the
channel I take those and and edit them
and compress them and then upload them
into their own institutional Moodle
shell so that they can watch them and
and learn from them
so that's been quite a challenge and
I've had to a - face to face classes
that have had a transition online as
well one of them is my intro to
humanities class at Milwaukee Institute
of Art and Design and that's that's
going pretty good I would say it's it's
a bit of a challenge to adapt it to to
mine but but we've managed and then my
business ethics class has been a bit
less of a challenge in part because I'd
already taught it as an online class so
I had a hundred and eight lecture videos
for that that I provide as supplementary
resources for the students when I teach
face-to-face and then those become part
of the core when we when we teach online
right and I may shoot some more videos
for that class as well this coming month
what else did you know a lot of work
with the Sadler's lectures podcast and
released a lot of content on Nietzsche
both on his truth and lies and an extra
moral sense and thus spoke zarathustra
part one and we also managed to release
all the videos or not the videos the
podcast episodes made from videos on
Blaise Pascal's passe so that's quite
good that's something to look forward to
and when it comes to videos I'm very
happy to
say that this month I was able to
produce a half-hour Haegele video that
felt really good to be able to get back
into it I'm looking forward to doing
more this month I also produced a video
doing a little bit of meme analysis on
Tralee memes having to do with Co vid 19
and say governmental and business
responses to it I did a book review
video on Peter Steinke which is
excellent excellent work on stoicism and
creativity link to that is below and I
did a video to help my fellow
instructors make the transition to
online some of you may be interested in
this if you want to get into video
production yourself it's called
bare-bones for video of producers and
I'll put a link to that as well the
radio show we managed to video record
one of the sessions obviously the one
that was in studio and I did some you
know core concept videos from my classes
release some on John Rawls theory of
Justice John Stuart Mill's on Liberty
and on Plato's Republic book form
the other thing that I did do quite a
bit of video production on but you're
not going to see coming out for quite a
while for my intro to humanities class
we're actually reading marjan satrapies
Persepolis vol 1 which is a graphic
novel and it's about growing up in Iran
under the Shah and then during the time
of the Revolution and then in the time
of the Islamic Republic and satrapy is
actually my age we're actually only a
few months apart in in our birthdays so
I'm you know I grew up in in the same
times remembering a lot of this stuff
happening I also grew up in a very media
literate family so I knew quite a bit of
what was going on in Iran from my
especially from my dad who followed the
events quite quite closely so for me I
understand you know the background of
the things that are happening in the
story but many of my students you know
who are all generations II they they
don't write and they can relate to it in
many ways on many of the themes but they
don't know some of the what you know
what's happening in that era so I've
been producing short lecture videos for
them going over aspects of the text I
might release those later on down the
line right now those are just for my my
ADD students so that's what's been going
on in March and let's talk about what's
gonna happen in April now we have quite
a few online events for the month of
April now one thing you definitely want
to remember is that I live here in
Milwaukee so I'm on central Daylight
Time The Times I'm gonna give are for
central Daylight Time so if you're in
any other time zone you need to figure
out when the event is orell so you might
show up too early or too late and then
be a bit disappointed you can always
look on the reason io comm calendar the
events calendar I keep that updated and
of course I also put a lot of these
events into my facebook page as events
so you can find them there as well so
let me run through them and I'll tell
you a little bit about each of them
along the way this Saturday on the
fourth two days from now at 12 p.m. we
kick off the month with a AMA that is
ask me anything session hosted on
YouTube live you want to get your
questions in early and if you are doing
the the AMA you know I I do give
preference to people who are asking
questions that haven't been asked before
so if you're asking about jejak or land
or stuff like that or peterson those
usually go by the wayside it's it's more
for for you know stuff that we haven't
talked about in previous AMA sessions
and I try to make sure that everybody
gets to ask a question so if you asked
20 questions I may not actually answer
all all of your questions so you know
get in early think about the questions
you want to ask and then I'll try to
answer them as best as I can on the 7th
which is a Tuesday at 6 p.m. we will
have our monthly meeting of the
Milwaukee chapter of Sofia Sofia is the
Society of philosophers in America it's
a national organization devoted to doing
public philosophy and you know making
philosophy accessible to everybody so we
are going to be discussing the themes of
isolation and loneliness and solidarity
something very timely for for this and
we'll be doing that in a zoom session I
will you know put the information in the
event site you can go to MKE Sofia and
Meetup and find the information there
you don't have to be in Milwaukee to
join in on this conversation obviously
we're gonna have people dropping in from
other areas although you know we are
trying to build a community of inquiry
here in Milwaukee we'll also be having
and I'm not sure exactly about the
scheduling for this so I can't give you
times but I can at least tell you I
think the the days on two of the Fridays
in this month of April coming up
probably on the 10th and then you know
it likely be the 24th will hopefully
have the wisdom for life radio show
doing new episodes it's up to the
station manager and he's kind of moving
the schedule around a little bit so I
can't say that it'll be at the normal
time of 5:00 p.m. it might be a 2 p.m.
and who knows so you want to like pay
attention to the station for that and
I'll have announcements about it as well
on my social media on the 11th that's a
Saturday at 12 p.m. we will have our
philosophy chat for patreon supporters
that is a perk for people at a certain
level of support of the work that I do
and it's a video conferencing thing
again they get to you know chat with me
one-on-one and annika conversations
about anything they want to and
philosophy on the 15th at 5:00 p.m.
we'll have our public
Haegele Q&A and discussion session
that's where you can come if you've got
questions about Hegel the half hour
Hegel Project German idealism philosophy
more generally I'm
make myself available for an hour just
to chat about these things with people
and that's that's being of course
supported by my patreon backers so you
can thank them for that
on the 18th at 12 p.m. that's a Saturday
I will be doing another workshop with
the stoah so I mentioned this is one of
the three big things the stoah is this
organization up in Toronto and they're
doing a lot of online programming a lot
of cool stuff and you know you can drop
into it I'm going to be doing a talk
this time specifically about isolation
and solitude and the opportunity of
cultivating and interior life and I'm
going to be drawing upon some ancient
philosophy Aristotle and the Stoics but
I'm also bringing in existentialist as
well particularly rainer maria rilke the
great poet and letter writer his letters
to a young poet frame solitude or I'm
Tom kite is a major conception of his
and it runs throughout the rest of his
works a bit of Nietzsche some other
figures as well perhaps Gabriel Marcel
so we'll be talking about that you're
perfectly you know welcome to join in
but but that's not something that I'm
running as an event I'm providing the
content but you have to sign up with
them in order to participate on their
site and I'll give you a link to that
below you always click more and you see
all this this wonderful stuff and here's
another big thing coming up and that I
mentioned on the 23rd at 1:00 p.m. I'm
going to be doing something quite new
we're calling it the classic metal Club
or classic metal chat I haven't quite
decided on it yet I'm gonna bring in a
few of my musician friends to give me
some feedback on that and I'm gonna be
meeting with people via zoom for about
an hour and a half I'm gonna do a
presentation and it's gonna be about you
know some of the history of heavy metal
so I'm gonna be focusing on you know
basically the early to
mid-seventies talking about the origins
and the the major early bands and the
cross influences between them and what
was going on it's not just about Black
Sabbath and then everything else
happening after them there were a lot of
other bands that were part of the
picture so I'm gonna do that and then
we'll have like an open Q&A and
discussion session I may in fact have
some guests who are also really
conversant in this stuff I'm hoping that
I might be able to for example bring in
my good friend Scott to rouille or
another one of my good friends bleach
six six well we'll see whether they're
available and whether they're they're up
to it they're both you know practicing
musicians who have done a lot of cool
stuff and have a lot of views on this
this sort of thing and we've had many
conversations about the history of it so
that that I'm really excited about that
and I'll put more news about that of
course in my social media the last big
event will be on the 30th last day of
the month 6:00 p.m. the MKE stoic
fellowship open to people outside of
Milwaukee we had somebody joining from
the Des Moines Stoics and somebody
joining from one of the Florida stoic
meetup groups that he runs this last
time we are you know of course a local
organization but it's open at this point
in time to other people joining in our
zoom meetings so if you're interested in
that you want to go to MKE
stoic fellowship and meet up and see
what we've got lined up the other thing
that I'll say is that I probably will do
some pop-ups over the course of the
months and once I actually get a bit
caught up on my schedule I'll I'll do
that as well and I'll do that through
YouTube live I've got a lot of class
work to do as usual I'm you know still
proceeding as well with all my business
related things the ethics consulting
philosophical counseling a few new
clients due to the the kovat crisis and
and anxieties about that and and you
know thinking about what to do
getting tapped by a couple organizations
to help them in other ways with
consulting so I'm doing some behind the
scenes
sorts of things and of course I've got
my regular you know classroom teaching
and then tutorials that I'm doing as
well for the podcast the samplers
lectures podcast I'm going to be doing
James William James's the will to
believe and then a lot of Epictetus
content and that will probably take me
through the month I do want to mention
something that's really cool that I
should have brought up before
so the Sadler's lectures podcast has now
been incorporated into the true sci-fi
channel which is a 24/7 streaming
channel of some of the best ideas
podcasts out there it's kind of nice
recognition they wrote me and said hey
can we incorporate your stuff you know
it's other things like history of
philosophy with no gaps and philosophy
bytes and stoic meditations and all
these other great philosophy oriented
podcasts so I said yeah of course sure
you can stream my content so that's
that's a cool development if I do get
epictetus done then I'll probably do a
poll about who I should do next in the
Sandler's lectures let's talk about
videos now and this will bring us to the
end of this rather long update I'm gonna
try to get six half-hour Haegele videos
done this month I want to get moving
back on that project and finish this
spirit section that I've been in for
several years now and get on to the
religion section which is the
second-to-last section of the work and
then it's sort of you know moving
downhill and I might actually finish the
half hour Haegele project probably not
this year but you know next year book
reviews I'm going to do some more book
reviews videos so stay tuned for those
I've got some really cool books that
have been sent to me
we'll have videos of quite a few of the
events of course the stoma workshop the
the the metal chat maybe a few other
things as well
core concept videos I'm going to be
shooting some stuff on Cicero's on
friendship
some other stuff on McIntyre's after
virtue and quite a few stuff on William
James is sa pragmatism all of which I
need for my courses if I can get to
anything else I will but I'm probably
this month gonna be doing some odds and
ends stuff so what do I mean by that
well when I shot for example my videos
on cow Moos myth of sisyphus I didn't
actually get to all of the videos that I
wanted to create right so there's a few
that that never got shot okay I'll do
those this month or you know there's an
ant some video on his de Libertad a that
I I need to shoot and there's a few
other odds and ends like that here
laying around sitting on my desktop as
thumbnails reminding me that I need to
get to them so hopefully this month I
will be able to get to them that's
everything that I've got on my end I
hope that all of you are healthy and
safe and well stocked up and I also hope
that I'll see some of you in these
online events that we have planned
whether it's something just to be
helpful for you or a nice distraction or
something in between
my hope is that these will be in some
way beneficial for you so hope to see
some of you there
and I hope all of you have as good a
month as possible in these circumstances
you